but brandon marsh has played like he
belongs here joe madden
could not stop raving about him in the
dugout before the ball game talking
about his baseball iq
this is a this is a hello moment to the
big leagues not only you're running out
at the big a but you got your own camera
person
patrick sandoval has been great those
numbers really we think about his whip
at 1.250 and nine starts
59 strikeouts in 56 innings pitched and
he's looked good against the mariners
this year
and that is on the outside corner
and we are underway one gone now
off of sandoval and he collapses to a
knee
and let's hope he's all right i got him
on his wrist area on the deflection
good news is a couple pitches he's all
right and he'll continue
here's the next pitch and this is popped
up near second base
should be an easy play camping under
making the grab on that one is the
shortstop iglesias two
on and two outs for the mariners here in
the first no score the banner will be
designated hitter luis terence
on the ground walsh well off the bag and
a wild throw
terrence is safe and he's on his way to
second hanniger has scored
here is france striding across the plate
and a bit of a defensive miscue for the
angels has given the mariners their
first two runs of the ball game
another 2-2 check swing
anyway big right-hander logan gilbert
getting his 11th start of the year since
coming up
in mid-may from the minor leagues from
triple a to comey's three and two with a
3.51 era
they appeal and they say that he goes
quick work of him
[Music]
and he goes reaching for one there a
couple of punch-outs for young logan
gilbert to get things going carving
through fletcher and now ohtani
walsh ready the wind-up and the 2-2 on
the way fastball
swing and a miss strike three and logan
gilbert strikes out the side here in the
bottom of the first inning how about
that
here's the 01 pitch ground ball hit the
short should be two flipped the second
one
relay to first in time and some money in
the bank right there
high up into the sun
eaton is there and he makes the catch
right now we're seeing a lot more of
that right there another strikeout
gilbert's been living with that heater
a ball put in play caught by mitch
haniger
another strikeout in the books here's
the one-two on the way slider swinging a
miss strike three and yes another
strikeout in the book
here's one that's popped in the air into
shallow left field
inching in and making the grab on that
one is taylor ward
hannigar to left and ward is there and
makes the catch
chopper mayfield goes to get it flips it
across in time
so the batter will be brandon marsh
rookie only 23 years old
sure he has a few butterflies as he digs
into the batter's box for the first time
as a major leaguer
[Music]
joe west rings them up
fletcher pops it up to dylan moore
use 0 for 2. i don't know if we've uh
said that
anytime recently base is loaded now
and two outs and jared walsh struck out
his first time up against gilbert
gilbert's 1-2 and he got him swinging
through the cheddar
here's designated hitter luis trent
here's the pitch of the way swinging a
fly ball deep into the gap in left
center field marsh going back looking up
and
goodbye baseball out to the rockery
laurice terrence with his 10th home run
of the season
home run out to bedrock over the wall
and left center field
and it's now the mariners three and the
angels nothing and this kid is in a
nice groove france one for three a base
hit
off of sandoval's left wrist in the top
of the first inning
france lays into one deep drive
left field ty france three run bomb
now the maritals have blown this game
open in the fifth inning number nine on
the year for france
six nothing mariners that's the minimum
five strikeouts but he's had traffic
last couple of innings been able to
pitch out of it but they put some
pressure on him
iglesias out to left bowers tracking it
and he gets him to foul it back to
murphy gets him with the slider again
that's the eighth strikeout today for
logan gilbert it matches a career best
gilbert's 3-2
into shadow center kellner can slow up
make the catch
for round number three
and a good change up and a swing and a
miss and sandoval
trying to give some length to the start
[Applause]
and he said he's re-found it but
sandoval
whatever issues he's had it looks like
in this inning he's cleaned it up his
last three hitters he struck out
that is patrick sandoval striking out
the side he's punched out four in a row
swing and a miss for strike three a
career
best nine strikeout efforts so far today
for logan gilbert
and the kid is up brandon marsh with
runners at the corners and one out
swinging right through elevated gas from
chigwa
the glaciers now line drive
base hit in the corner
stassi will score ward will score and
iglesias has
the angels on the board 13th double
29 rbis for jose iglesias
two for three today
pulls a little weird hop but france is
there and he
did not get to the bag ohtani
busting hard that's incredible
that is incredible speed all the other
things we talk about
the tools he has how do you beat that
out i have no idea enough room to put
murphy
and he walks a man with the bases loaded
it's a 7-2 mariners lead as haniger
scores
this is about one of the few things left
to be decided in this game the way it
looks
will he get the hit to keep the hitting
streak going
way up and in and a swing and a miss
that almost hit fletcher in the face
strike three
so david fletcher's 26 game hitting
streak is gonna come to an end
three two ottani right center field
and deep and gone
34. so the angels still have a little
life
left in them here in this bottom of the
ninth inning with two outs and max
stassi will be in the next batter
he goes and that's the game the mariners
win it 7-4
and they open up the second half with a
series win against the angels